19 years of spider-man movies have made
for some fantastic special effects we're
talking perfectly detailed digital
creations skyscraper scaling and
high-flying stunts it's time for 30
scenes without cgi from the spider-man
movies from the og sam raimi films to
the epic spider-man no way home number
one well the concrete jungle at least by
this point zendaya and tom holland are
used to holding each other tight whether
hanging out themselves or well hoisted
up with harnesses
it was a big swing the best part of this
terrifying stunt was definitely the fact
that zendaya didn't have to pretend to
be terrified at all thank you
number two does tom ever get lightheaded
actually going into this impossible
challenge
seriously that's a lot of time for a
regular person to spend hanging upside
down luckily the blood of rushing to his
head doesn't have any effect on his
acting abilities
oh my god
number three no need to stop the vehicle
he'll just hop off when he needs to it's
the spidey way tom looks so natural
doing this it almost seems like he could
probably pull it all off without the
wires
for the record i do all my own stunts
number four
is this a hospital we've got two docks
in the house and all the tense vibes it
might be a fairly small set in reality
but the cgi really gives the space the
character and depth to make it a
powerful moment between the trio they've
got the technology
this isn't gonna be a problem number
five and it's parkour time not a wire in
sight we're becoming more and more
convinced poland is actually a real-life
spider-man
well i do all of my own stunts
run spidey run number six
ready for a giant explosion the scale of
what they have is not to be
underestimated boom goes that dynamite
holding back really isn't a thing they
do on the spider-man set
real pyrotechnics make the explosions
cgi fine-tunes it all
number seven ouch that is a lot of
floors to go through it just puts you
right back on your game luckily their
crew was so good they made it possible
to shoot pretty much anything safely but
still this is next level number eight
that's one way to go off-roading for
sure how many cars are we guessing were
harmed during the making of this film or
guardrails for that matter even without
the added effects these shots behind the
scenes ooze with action
number nine
when was the last time you saw snow
flurrying down casually in the middle of
atlanta georgia we down here in georgia
baby down here in georgia when they
couldn't actually film in new york cgi
and practical effects came in to save
the day and bring the right season to
the screen
number 10 the sheer scale of this the
production team knew how to bring the
real wreckage combined with zenday and
jacob bringing the drama the cgi team
producing scenery magic a perfect recipe
for success
number eleven okay so how many cars are
we thinking had to be completely
destroyed to capture enough material for
the cgi team to work with few studios
are actually able to bring stunts at
this scale to life but the team behind
spider-man well they've obviously got it
covered number 12
tough conversations intense realities
this set served total meeting room
realness and of course the special
effects team managed to design the
perfect environment
are we surprised by this point
number 13. why land on the ground when
you can land on a car just another day
filming in the middle of a highway
making spider-man history nice work tom
a mile we pressed for time come on let's
do two number 14. hold up is that a far
from home spidey suit we see yes it is
but it wasn't the only spidey suit that
they filmed this scene in that day we
never really think about the fact that
seemingly simple street scenes could
require special effects but voila
number 15. okay so how magical is this
evening on the bridge we'll admit the
blue screen instead of the river and
night sky aren't quite the same but the
bond between holland and jake gyllenhaal
he's the nicest guy i like the world he
is i'm i'm super into him as
spider-man yeah but you're like the
greatest action of our generation well
we know that bro love is real
number 16 who will it be today hydro man
molten man sandman a mix of all three
the fully cgi rendered villains steal
the scene and really make waves
okay well at least hydroman does
number 17 did you see an out of place
aircraft the actors running from it
didn't but we definitely believe they do
this cgi is pretty flawless no surprise
considering how intricately designed it
was from the beginning
number 18 is the monument scale while
they couldn't really film at the
monument holland still got to show off
all his scaling skills on the smaller
build in studio
they weren't going to make it easy for
him and film horizontally though you
know we got the real deal
we didn't have to like film it sideways
we didn't have to turn the camera
sideways and see how it looked
afterwards number 19 are all the people
supposed to just stop like that you bet
every single actor in this scene is
literally holding still his statues it
turned out to be the easiest way to pull
off this spidey sense scene and took a
ton of practice from these expert
performers
for the five or six minutes it took for
the cannon to move through
at least all the spider-man madness was
filmed separately trying to stay still
while cars are flying so close yeah no
thanks
number 20. would you believe us if we
said this flying spider-man wasn't in
fact andrew garfield but a fully virtual
spider-man the shaky and exciting camera
work was done by hand as the operator
actually reacted to watching the virtual
simulation moving
number 21 need a sewer cgi has you
covered this scene literally wouldn't
have been possible without cgi because
that's what the whole thing is although
andrew garfield wasn't able to get out
of being totally soaked
number 22
it's time for the digital lizard
this fierce creature was totally cgi all
of its shots in the movie were indeed
thanks to vfx
but that didn't mean the actions and
reactions were just plucked from thin
air combine the captured movements of
the actor with the reptile cgi skin and
voila the best digital lizard we have
ever seen
number 23 it's a symbiote day today
isn't it luckily toby didn't have to
deal with the terrifying black slime
they had vfx for that considering how
long ago these effects were actually
created remember this is early 2000s
they're super impressive and intricate
and thanks to that cgi no tobey mcguires
were harmed in the making of this film
with great power
comes great fun number 24
is he though is he really back with that
less than climactic landing luckily
karma didn't get it back for faking an
injury and toby got to safely fall in
the hold of his harness
number 25
okay so there was some cgi included to
bring that full cityscape but the web
itself that sweet mj and peter moment on
the web actually happened
honestly i never think about it while
i'm making it but i just knew that i
just felt like it was special we can't
lie we absolutely want to experience
hanging out on that web number 26
while the cgi doc awk for spider-man no
way home had some epic looking arms
the tentacles
are all kind of cg now the fact that
alfred molina actually had puppet limbs
surrounding him filming spider-man 2 is
super epic they were mechanical and i
had them like you know attached to me
and we had puppeteers working them and
stuff eight arms versus two though
hardly fair really
number 27
let's take a second to recognize just
how much action aunt may got in this
movie rosemary harris did a lot of
stunts too
she's swinging around and flying through
the air nearly as much as spider-man
himself obviously with a different vibe
though props to rosemary harris on this
one who literally dove into doing some
of her own stunts after seeing an older
stunt person pull them off i begged them
to and they relented and it was lovely i
loved it number 28
i think we worked on the train sequence
certainly from day one to the very very
end
usually people ride home inside the
train car but if on top is more your
thing then hey you do you
it was easy to see and to be able to
read between the lines early on that
there was going to be a lot of cgi work
involved quantity of work dictated that
we should probably shoot some real
trains somewhere
the train itself was real but thank
goodness that speed was not
number 29
the big apple is a cool city for sure
but they weren't so keen on all the wild
shots the spider-man team needed to
capture so the always wonderful vfx team
brought new york to spider-man land
sometimes it's a completely cg shot
picture perfect
you bet we don't expect anything less
from this team
number 30.
is he okay
oh yeah he's just doing his green goblin
thing it's a whole lot less green but
just as intense without the cgi you want
to know the truth
nobody knows how uncomfortable those
costumes are
went full goblin beast mode here wow
that's pretty nutty the cgi and special
effects in these movies has come a long
way but from the very start it's been
impressive we love seeing how certain
characters have changed visually over
the years especially those that went
from giant puppets to full cgi
which is your favorite special effect
[Music]